E com isso você provavelmente a única
speaker que vai falar de máscara e vocês
vão perceber Porque durante a toca mas
acabei de receber uma mensagem no amigo
meu espanhol me disse agora é que vais
deixar crescer o cabelo o bizote tanto
para provar que não tenho bigode e
é basicamente que eu vou falar de
literacia científica mas ele travessia
científica numa perspectiva diferente
falamos muito de literacia científica
durante a pandemia a minha perspectiva é
um pouco diferente eu vivo Inglaterra
portanto peço desculpa se vez em quando
aparecer algumas palavras inglesas
basicamente isso tu foi uma carta do
governo Inglês mandado no dia vinte
março de 20 portanto conta para Mia foi
declarada isso é uma carta mandada a 3.8
milhões de Ingleses Inglaterra só que é
basicamente oito por cento da população
Eles foram foram avisados que estavam
identificados como clinicamente
extremamente vulneráveis a riscos de
doença Severa e morte eu recebi esta
carta também e posso dizer que receber
uma carta destas é um só
Ah e não é fácil lidar com isso é
diferença é que eu tenho literacia
científica e portanto conforme seguia as
informações podia tomar as minhas
próprias decisões o que esta carta
também diz é que não devemos sair de
casa não podemos ir trabalhar não
podemos ir às compras não devemos
encontrar com ninguém se vivemos com
alguém em casa dizemos metemos a dois
metros da pessoa devemos comer sozinhos
no quarto e as únicas exceções são
Profissionais de Saúde que nos visitam
ou visitas a hospitais não podemos se
Queres ver o médico de família a carta
avisa que isto será para os próximos
três meses pelo menos
é basicamente a diferença de vida destes
três. 8 milhões de pessoas oito por
cento da população inglesa foi o grau de
literacia de ciência deles porque nós
falamos defeitos falamos do trampo que
diz mas aletra Cia científica fases uma
diferença real Na vida de muita gente no
dia a dia e importante todos nós como
indivíduos contribuiu Contri vamos
façamos um esforço para mudar isto
basicamente a literacia científica como
vocês sabem disso é considerado um
direito de cidadania é importante não só
tá democracia portanto indevido só pode
usufrir do país onde vive se compreender
os desenvolvimentos científicos e
tecnológicos só pode usar as resources
os recursos médicos se souber o que
existe
e em termos de desenvolvimento Eco
social para o país porque não temos
cidadãos com o mínimo base de
conhecimentos científicos não é possível
treiná-los não é preciso desenvolver o
país tecnologicamente economicamente
agora o que a diretoria científica não é
é uma biblioteca dos Fatos e muitas
vezes a literacia científica nos
apresentados com isso e importante que
se vamos que não é interessante é
fantástico saber imenso a ciência mas a
literacia científica é um instrumento
para uma vida de melhor qualidade
Ah e não é uma medalha de mérito também
começamos haver muitos eventos de letras
super ciências se transformam
espetáculos e não é e peço desculpa
porque isto faz realmente o barulho ao
respirar eu não respirar sim
e o problema é como é que nós queremos
uma sociedade com literacia científica
as nossas noções de letra científicas
vem da escola e como sabem da escola por
enquanto Embora esteja a fazer fortes
como ele as horas do anterior disse
continuamos a ter muitas limitações em
termos de qualidade conhecimentos
científicos que sai dos alunos portanto
quando saímos da escola de onde saiu a
nossa literacia científica neste momento
infelizmente vem principalmente dos
meios de comunicação social da história
de formas sociais e das celebridades são
tudo isto é extremamente complicado e
nós vimos companhia o número de pessoas
que diz que não se vacina com o número
de pessoas que não quer usar máscara
é a forma de controle de compras de
atacar Isto é que uma comunicação de
ciência é comunicação de ciência para a
maioria das pessoas e os cientistas a
falar mas é muito mais do que isso
existe uma classe enorme de
comunicadores de ciências do qual ele
faz parte o problema da da comunicação
de ciência é que os modelos que existem
meditação de ciência um Elmo o que
chamamos do défice cognitivo parte do
princípio que a população não conhece
gostava dos mostrar neste interessante
aquilo é um uma Como é que chama uma
batata cientista foi desenhado por mim
porque esse é o modelo do défice
cognitivo parte-se do princípio que a
população não sabe nada veio o cientista
veio comigo assim todo ciência explica a
essência não vamos mudar a literacia
científica
o portal desta forma Este é o segundo
modelo em que se estabelece um diálogo
conversas fala se Mas o problema de tudo
isto é que neste momento da comunicação
de ciência é feita por organizações
científicas e cientistas O que é
fantástico eles fazem coisas
extremamente interessantes mas fazem
Aquilo em que trabalham e pouco mais do
que isso portanto acabamos para perder o
mundo inteiro que que é produzir e
trazia científica na população em geral
e que não têm oportunidade de fazer
porque não há dinheiro
nós precisamos no novo Paradigma e é
isso que eu vou falar que eu projeto que
eu estou muito interessado basicamente o
que temos que ir é dentro da comunidade
perguntar a comunidade O que é que eles
precisam que é uma coisa que não estamos
a fazer e que é necessário por exemplo
uma das coisas mais complicadas que
temos em relação à comunicação de
ciência e provavelmente todos vocês
fazem parte desse grupo é que quem vai
aos eventos de comunicação de ciência
são pessoas de classe média educadas e
brancas penso que todos os mais ou menos
cinco a drones tudo e por cento acabamos
ficar presos dentro do universo igual a
si mesmo e o precisamos pensar é como é
que vamos quebrar isto a forma de cobrar
Isto é ir dentro das Comunidades e
perguntares o que é que vocês precisam
Qual é a ciência que vocês precisam para
melhorar vosso dia a dia porque a minha
travessia de ciência científica tem que
ser
e como instrumento de mudança é um
instrumento no dia a dia
e eu vou chorar agora do projeto
obviamente como clinicamente
extremamente vulnerável sei se esta
ordem das palavras em português está
muito próximo do que eu do que me
interessa eu tenho uma doença que tem
deste dos meus 9 anos e desde os meus 9
anos obviamente ainda mãe que a médica
que fez inicialmente fiz hoje por mim e
a partir de uma certa altura sou eu que
tomei as minhas decisões e não tenho
dúvidas de que o resultado da minha
doença resultou das minhas decisões
inteligentes
e a verdade é que a maioria dos doentes
quer ser parte das decisões O problema é
que não só
e o problema é que os obstáculos que diz
é uma não sabem não sabem a ciência para
poder falar a segunda não se sentem
confiantes a terceira não sente não
sentei com os profissionais de saúde os
apoio e a quarta tem problemas que o
sistema
há portanto como é que podemos trabalhar
com isto só para vocês terem uma ideia
do problema de desigualdades de saúde na
literacia de saúde ou seja as diferenças
que faz ter ou não letras e de saúde
Isto é as perdas financeiras por ano só
na Inglaterra
com 36 milhões de euros em produtividade
ou seja gente que durante um ano ficou
doente sem necessidade simplesmente não
tinha literacia científica de saúde o
estado pagou 30 milhões de euros não
precisava pagar se essa gente perceber
se a ciência da Saúde o serviço Nacional
de saúde gastou 6.5 milhões de euros e
este o próximo é o que mais impressão de
faz por ano perna esse dois milhões de
anos por morte prematura Isto é os
resultados da falta de literacia de
saúde a literacia de saúde não é Acerca
das fakes News na acerca do não vacinar
é Acerca das mortes que poderiam ser
evitadas e que todos nós podemos ter um
papel principalmente como classe-média
educada
o Ok então vamos falar do eventos que eu
resolvi fazer para trabalhar nisto
conhecerão todos os problemas que os
obstáculos que os doentes apresentam
para poder e se envolver nas suas
decisões resolvi criar um evento que não
sei se vocês apanham afiada comigo e se
mostrar que basicamente é bem cinco
every one to know about depois é uma
doença da cozinha Eva África A ideia é
ter um evento extremamente informal e o
trabalho eu fiz uma exatamente aí o
professor portanto os meus contatos
também for também a ideia era trazer
cientistas de Oxford se clínicos
especialistas numa determinada doença
cada o workshop é uma doença todas as
doenças com que o trabalho são crônicas
pela simples razão de que é fazer a
travessia científica será um instrumento
para a vida destas pessoas porque uma
doença crônica a partir do momento que
aparece desaparece quando eles morrer né
bom e então o contexto forma como aquilo
funciona É temos um clínico tem em mim e
temos um voluntário ensinamos não só a
ciência da doença mas também a ciência
dos tratamentos fazemos exercícios com
eles para testar pseudociência e
ensinamos o método científico isso é
algo que toda a gente acha que não é
possível fazer em adultos EA realidade é
que é possível desde que vocês Desde que
seja feito de uma forma inteligente e a
forma inteligente e isso é que é
interessante é com empatia é arranjar um
ambiente onde as pessoas estejam
confortáveis para perguntar as questões
e as nossas workshops são das Nove às
cinco da tarde Isto é gente' com Artrite
reumatoide é pessoas com cancro muitas
com cancro terminal e só tivemos em
todas as workshops que eu fiz só
queremos uma pessoa que saiu a
o e saiu a meio porque recebeu uma
chamada de um oncologista dela a dizer
que não tinha cancro e portanto só
obviamente um ficou nua que já foi
cobrar só para nos dar uma ideia do
feedback ou seja dos resultados que nós
tivemos a qualidade do evento como vocês
verem participante quase oitenta por
cento das pessoas dizem que estar o que
achar um excelente e o tempo restante em
36 ciência mudou muito ou 6 esteja gente
que vai passar Está confortável a
perguntar sobre a sua da sua doença a ir
à procura da informação nós pedimos os
três palavras que definissem o evento e
esta é o Word Cloud que produto e tanto
a minha a palavra que eu mais gosto é
friendly e Funny
é porque se vocês querem trazer a gente
de todo tipo tem que fazer coisas que
elas gostem e nós tivemos desde uma
velhinha de 80 anos que obviamente não
percebeu nada do que se passava por ter
que era surda mas adorou estar lá porque
conhecimentos a gente almoçou conosco
fez Network fez amigos tivemos imensa
gente que disse que tinha aprendido
muito que estava muito mais confortável
há um ano depois
é uma um problema de disse Beck muito
tempo depois é que a maioria não
respondi portanto os únicos que tínhamos
em 7 pessoas é quem podíamos pedir
feedback que eram os únicos que tinham
passado um ano recebemos de 6 mas o que
é interessante é todos eles passaram a
ser doentes ativos tanto é possível
e o que vimos que ganharam literacia
científica prática é possível fazer
exemplos dentro mudam-se as pessoas o
evento inclusive estamos problema está
com os dias as pessoas que vão aos
eventos são sempre as mesmas nestes
casos Eventos São inclusivos Porque se
todo o percurso junto as pessoas é
doença EA doença não é discriminatória
qualquer pessoa
a adaptação a diferentes níveis de
litros um dos grandes problemas da
literacia de saúde é que todas as
científica que toda a gente tem uma
letra Silva acerca diferente o facto de
ser o evento em que estamos lá e temos
empatia que estamos a conversar com ele
faz com que possamos explicar Qual a
qualquer pessoa independentemente do
nível de letras EA Saúde São
oportunidade de rosto de criar relações
de afeto existem extremamente esta
última interessante que é das mais
importantes porque eu queria as relações
afetivas com outras pessoas contribue
para juntas poderem fazer uma diferença
na forma como o sistema de saúde da com
ela
a mensagem isto é mais uma mensagem para
a comunidade científica é que tem que
ver dinheiro para os free lance
comunidades que não existe neste momento
o dinheiro tá nas instituições tá ligado
aos cientistas e somos nós os três
lances que temos a capacidade de fazer
literacia científica que não está
necessariamente ligada às instituições e
como tal pode ser muito mais criativa
é só para acabar uma história já que eu
comecei com uma história triste uma
história teste de este senhor com
aquela/lá em cima muito jeitosa é um
familiar meu durante toda a vida é uma
pessoa que eu gosto muito durante toda a
vida foi um atleta Tem sim trouxe preto
de judo fazia km h mergulhava e há cerca
de oito anos desenvolveu uma neuropatia
autoimune periférica basicamente o
sistema e modelo deixou de reconhecer as
terminações nervosas das mãos dos pés e
depois espalha-se para os braços e faz
pernas neuropatias alto é muito
periféricos são muito chatas porque uma
raras O que quer dizer que não se pode
fazer ensaios clínicos porque não há
doentes suficientes para fazer os
ensaios clínicos então acaba por ser um
saco de várias doenças com os mesmos
sintomas e que torna as coisas
complicadas para tratar a um tratamento
genérico
em algumas pessoas funciona a outras Não
e aqui e esta pessoa durante muitos anos
funcionou até o dia em que deixou de
funcionar e ele começou a dizer a doença
e para uma pessoa que era atlética ele
entrou no hospital andar e sair uma
cadeira de rodas
há algumas semanas Depois teve que
comprar uma cadeira de rodas elétrica
porque já não conseguia sequer mover as
mãos para empurrar a cadeira de rodas eu
quando sou viste como cálculo Este é um
choque e como eu acredito na literacia
científica e no uso prático como
instrumento do dia a dia fui procurar o
que é que a literatura dizia e
basicamente a literatura não existe
havia estudos com quatro cinco doentes
não havia nada concreto pudesse ser
usado nele e é por causa disso que os
médicos não tinham tentado mas havia um
medicamento que aliás é o menos um
medicamento que ele como nós sabemos que
é de que a doença é mediada por
anticorpos e depois da academia já toda
a gente sabe o que é anticorpos e o
medicamento que eu tomo tirar as células
produzem antibióticos anticorpos e
configurando que eu venho de Oxford
tivemos uma conversa com o médico dele e
conseguimos convencer a testar um
medicamento
e eu estava na cadeira de rodas e agora
anda sem sequer precisar dela só
basicamente isto prova o que a literacia
científica pode fazer e é uma história
que para mim estimular continuar a fazer
a diferença e espero que você tenha
convencido que vale a pena investir na
letra C científica do verdadeira
perfeito e os todas essas coisas
realmente não são importantes e vacinas
obrigado a